قال ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان في افتتاح القمه العربيه الصينيه
بالرياض ان القمه العربيه الصينيه تؤسسه
لمرحله جديده في تطوير علاقات الدول
العربيه والصين وتعزيز الشراكه بين
الجانبين وقال الرئيس الصيني السجن الذي
كان قد شارك في قمه خليجيه صينيه قبل ذلك
ان القمه العربيه تفصيليه حدث للصليب في
تاريخه على قاتل الجانبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر
ما دلاله العقائد القمه العربيه الصينيه
في هذا التوقيت وما مدى دقه الحديث عن
رؤيه العربيه الموحده تجاه العلاقه مع
الصين وما هي الافاق المحتمله للتعاون بين
الصين والعرب وما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه كل
طرف للاخر في ظل الاستقطاب القائم بين
القوه الكبرى في العالم وعلى اي نحو يمكن
ان تنظر واشنطن لهذا التقارب بالعربيه
الصينيه والخليجيه على وجه الخصوص وما
خياراتها للتعامل مع وجود صيني اكبر في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
قمه ثاني استضافات هم الرياض اليوم الجمعه
احداهما خليجيه الصينيه عقبتها اخرى عربيه
صينيه
بحثت افاق التعاون بين بيجين من ناحيه
والعرب ولا سينما الخليجيين من الجانب
الاخر
السعوديه
في علاقات الجانبيه
تعبدوا مجلس التعاون جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه شركه اساسيه مهمه لها وقد انعكست
ثمار ايجابيه لهذه الشراكه على مصالحنا
مشتركه وعلى امن منطقتنا واستقرارها وان
النمو الاقتصادي المتسارع وتطورات التقنيه
الكبير الذي وصلت اليه جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه تحت قياده فخامه
الصين الرائده الاقتصاديه العالميه
وتوليدو ان الاهميه
والتبادل الخبرات وخلق شركات متنوعه في
الخطوط الثانويه
وبالتنوع الواضح في مجالات التعاون
الاستراتيجي بين الجانبين
تنزيل
عميقه متبادله بين الجانبين اذا ان الصين
ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
تتبادلان دوما الدعم لمبدا سياده الدول
واستقلالها
وتحترم طروقها التنمويه وتتمسك بالمساواه
بين جميع الدول
عن تعدديه الاطراف هناك درجه عاليه من
التكامل بين الجانبين في الصين تتمتعوا
بسوق استهلاكه واسعه ومنظومه صناعيه
متكامله بينما يتميز الجانب الخليجي
بموارد الطاقه الغنيه
والتطوري المزدهر لتنويع الاقتصاد ما يجعل
منهما شاركين طبيعيين للتعاون
يؤسس العقاد هذه القمه للمرحله الجديده
العلاقه بين دولنا وتحديد الشراكه في
مجالات المشتركه من اجل تحقيق المستقبل
يطمح له شعوبنا لتنعم الاجيال القادمه
بالرخاء المنشود علينا بواسطه تحديد
التعاون في المجالات التجاريه
والاستثماريه والماليه بين الدول العربيه
والصين
في اطارات ثنائي والمتعدد وتطوير تنسيق
السياسي على سائح الدوليه تجاه القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الرياض
عبد العزيز بن رازق من المستشار بمركز
الاعلام والدراسات العربيه الروسيه
للدراسات الدوليه واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه
عبد العزيز بن راسم
بدايه
الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد السعودي
وايضا الرئيس الصيني والصفاء هذه القمه
بانه استثنائيه
ما الذي يجعله استثنائيه
تحيه لك سيد الفاضل وجملائي ضيوفك من كل
مكان الحقيقه يعني هذا الوصف عن البليغ
يعني يحمل مفهوم عميق في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه العلاقات الدوليه في
النظر
للتواجد القوي الروسي وخاصه على الساحه
الاقتصاديه وتوجه العالم او الثلثين
العالم الى شنغهاي والبركست اصبحت الصين
نحط انذار العالم السوق الصيني غزت حتى
اسواق الاوروبيه والغربيه وهذا يعني
بجوده عاليه بشكل يعني تاكيد كلمه سمو ولي
العهد على اهميه هذه الزياره
تكتسب يعني عده سياقات السياقه الاول ان
الصين يعني تتميز بعلاقات متينه ومنذ عقود
والمنشوبها اي تباين اطلاقا كما شاب بعض
العلاقات الغربيه في بعض التبعينات
والسبب في وجهه نظري يرجع الى ان الحكم في
الصين يعني مستقر وثابت وهو منذ عقود
يحكمها الحزب حزب واحد الحكم الشيوعي
بينما في بعض الدول هناك تواف يعني تواثر
الادارات على
القرش الحكم يلغي بعض الاتفاقيات للاسف
وراء عينه ذلك في تابعين الاداره
الامريكيه هنا كانت هناك صفه على الحوثيين
ومن تم رفعها او اعادها وهذا يعني يؤكد
هناك يعني هذا القلب الحقيقه ان هذه القمه
العالم وانا تابعته وسائل الاعلام
العالميه وجدت اهتمام كبير وخصوصا العالم
الان اصبح يتوجه الشرقا وهذه اثبتتها
الاقتصاديه بالدرجه الاولى
ما الذي تريده من المنطقه العربيه بما انه
هذه قمه استثنائيه وهمم لقاء استثنائي
وتاريخي تاريخي ما الذي الصين من هذا
اللقاء الاستثنائي
اعتقد ان زياره همم
لرئيس الصيني
فعلا تاريخيه وحدثوا الاستثنائي
وقد رفع ذلك العلاقات السعوديه همم
الصينيه السعوديه والعربيه والخليجيه الى
مستوى الاعلى
هذه همم الشراكه مهمه جدا بالنسبه للصين
للتعامل مع كل دوله عربيه
على اساس المساواه وبين الصين
والبلدان العربيه لا احد يحاول ان يفرض
تقاليده معتقداته ونقبل اختلافاتنا
ان نبني علاقات همم اقتصاديه
وتجاريه مع الدول العربيه
وسيظل الامر يتقدم والتعاون بين الصين
العرب
التواصل في مجال البنيه التحتيه
ومن المهم ايضا ان يتم توسيعه وزيادته في
مجال الدفاع
هو بريشن كويس
تعزيز التعاون سيكون ذلك مهما مع كل من
البلدان العربيه
الصين تدعم
القضيه الفلسطينيه
المشروعه وحقوقه المشروع حقوقها المشروعه
لان الصين
ليس هناك كثير من الوقت للسرد كل شيء لانه
في الواقع هذه العلاقات قديمه ايضا هي
الصين والعالم العربي لم يكتشف بعضا او
بعضهما بعضا اليوم نرجع علاقات قديمه
وعلاقات تجاريه ايضا عميقه همم بين العالم
العربي وبين الصين وفي الواقع بين الصين
وكل دول العالم الدكتور خليل العناني هل
هل ما حدث في الرياض يمثل اي همم همم
انعتاق في استراتيجي عربي ناحيه الشرق
وناحيه الصين ام انه كما قال وزير
الخارجيه السعودي همم
العلاقه مع شريك لا تعني همم همم ان
الشريك الاخر اصبح في حكم الملغي
اولا تحيه لكم تسجيل الضيوف ولكل
المشاهدين اعتقد ونوع من التحول في
الاجواء الاقليميه والدوليه لازم ضروري
تحاول استراتيجي في هذه اللحظه على الاقل
لكنه هناك محاوله عربيه بقياده السعوديه
من اجل التنويع
الحلفاء الدوليين خاصه في ظل اولا حاله
استقطاب عالميه
على اوكرانيا نتيجه لوجود نوع من الصراع
او التنافس او الخلاف همم الامريكي الصيني
وفي نفس الوقت لك الشعور عربي متزايد خاصه
شعور خليجي بوجود نوع من التخلي الامريكي
عن المنطقه العربيه خاصه في ظله الاهداف
الامنيه خاصه من قبل ايران وبالتالي نحن
ايذاء مرحله جديده في علاقات دوليه
ومحاوله لاستخدام او الاستفاده من هذا
الخلافه الموجود بين الكبير بين الصين من
جهه من جهه الاخرى من اجل تعظيم مكاسب
العربي اعتقد هذه يعتبر استراتيجيه ذكيه
جدا وحديقه سواء من قبل السعوديه او من
قبل الدول العربيه من اجل عدم الاتهام
لحليف واحد فقط هو امريكا وبالتالي الخضوع
لمنطق القطب الواحد او الحليف الواحد همم
لكن له اعتقد هذه اللحظه على الاقل نادي
يمثل تحول الاستراتيجيه لا تزال امريكا هي
عنصر فاعل حليف قوي جدا لدواء الخليج
العربي وخدوه العربيه بشكل عام هناك
ترتيبات امنيه قويه هناك مشاركه
استراتيجيه موجوده وبالتالي قد تكون هذه
المساله نوع من المناوره العربيه
والخليجيه فيما يتعلق بالاستفاده من
خلافات الموجوده على الساحه الدوليه على
نمط يوسف بشكل او باخر نمط الحرب البارده
خلال النصف الاخير
طيب اقول مره اخرى الى ضيفه من الرياض
السيد عبد العزيز
معروف ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه العرب للصين
همم المنطقه العربيه هي منطقه همم
ثروات نفطيه ومواد خام كثيره تحتاجها
الصين في نمو الصناعي وتعتمد عليها اصلا
لكن ما الذي يتوقعه العرب من الصين هل
هنالك مواقف صينيه يريد العرب ان تغيرها
الصين مثلا
حقيقه لها موقفين يعني
تاريخيا واخذ بالقضيه هل الفلسطينيه
وموقفها من خلال
تاييد القرار الخليجي الحيادي في الحرب
الاوكرانيه وهذا بكل تاكيد يعني يعني اكسب
دول العائد الدول العربيه والخليجيه حتى
الدول الشرقيه استقرار في السواق الطاقه
واستفادت الصين من هذه بالله وكما نعلم
لكن هذه مواقف يعني قائمه بحد ذاتها قبل
هذه القمم وقائمه بعد هذه القمه ما الذي
يريد العرب تغييره في السياسه الصينيه وهل
طلبوها اصلا
ما يحتاج العرب هو انه سين الان اصبحت
تتربى على كرسي التقنيه والصناعات التي
غزت الاسواق العالميه وهناك تعاملات قويه
جدا جدا حتى الدول الغربيه اصبحت تتعامل
يعني بمعصين في هذه كسوك يعني كبيره وسوق
رائع همم
والحقيقه يعني هناك توجهات كبيره وهذه
يعني المعطيات والاسياسه الثابت الى الصين
واحترامها على الاتفاقيات الدوليه جعل
الدول الخليج تنظر الى الصين كحاليل
استراتيجي وهذا كما قال ولي العهد لا يلغي
الحليفه الاخر
والحقيقه يعني اصبحت هناك تحولات ظهور
اقطاب جديده وكانت تسيدها الولايات
المتحده ولكن يعني الوقت الحالي ونرى يعني
الدخول بعض الاقتصاديات الاوروبيه من
الانتقالها من الانكماش الى مرحله الركود
هذه مؤشر خطير ولذلك الدول الشرق وخاصه
الصين والهند واصبح العالم يعني يتعامل
معها بكل ثقه بل يعمل هناك خطط استراتيجيه
بعيده المدى في سبيل الكل رابع شرقا
والمنطقه العربيه بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي
طبيعه التعاون في المرحله المقبله كيف
سيكون شكله الدكتور افيكتور جاو يعني
العلاقات العربيه الامريكيه فيها جانب
عسكري هل هذا الجاني ممكن ان ينتج عن هذه
القمم الاربعه التي عقدت في الرياض
عايزين
ان التعاون
العربي الصيني يشمل كل شيء ويشمل كل شيء
يمكن ان نفكر فيه ولكن فيما يتعلق بالدفاع
والعسكريه هناك امكانيات كبيره لدى الصين
وسيكون هناك امور كثيره تحدث
والتعاون مع الدول العربيه
ليس هناك
فحفوظات بالنسبه للصين لتقديم اا افضل
التكنولوجيات العسكريه والانظمه السياسيه
العسكريه للدول العربيه وهذا يختلف عن بعض
البلدان الاخرى التي لا تثق بالدول
العربيه ولا تريد ان تبيعها افضل الانظمه
العسكريه واعتقد ان الدول العربيه
يمكن ان تتعاون مع الصين في مجال الدفاع
بما فيه ذلك
يمكن
هل هنالك موانع عربيه دكتور خليل العناني
هل هل هل هذا الامر بهذه السهوله هل اذا
وافقت الصين على نقل تكنولوجيا الى العالم
العربي هل الامر بهذه السهوله
هناك تنافس امريكي صيني كبير جدا متعلق
التكنولوجيا
وراينا وتابعنا اثناء فتره ترامب الرئاسيه
كان هناك خلاف حول التكنولوجيا الصينيه
خاصه اللي ما اتعلم شركه هواوي
وهناك رفض امريكا لهذه المساله بشكل قاطع
لانه هناك مخاوف من استخدام هذه
التكنولوجيا لا يتجسس امريكا من العالم
الجميع خليفه الدول العربيه خاصه بالخليج
العربي وبالتالي اي استخدام عربي
لتكنولوجيا الصينيه قد يؤثر بالسلب عدد
الامن القانون الامريكي او بالثلاثه باريس
سهوله على الاطلاق نحن تنافس لم يكن صراع
امريكا صيني يمتد من اقصى بحر الصين
الجنوبي وحتى افريقيا واوروبا حتى وكذلك
بشكل افضل وبالتالي من الصعب القيام قيام
الدول العربيه بتخلي او بمحاولات تنصهمات
اتجاه امريكا
تكنولوجيا الامريكيه خاصه في مساله
الاتصالات
قد يكون هناك نقل التكنولوجيا الصينيه في
مساحات اخرى مثلا ما تتعلق
بالتنميه الزراعيه التنميه الصنا هي
الاستثمارات في البنيه التحتيه كل هذه
المسائل المسائل المشروعه ومسموح بها لكن
اي تغيير قطاعات اخرى تكون الصعب نقله دي
تكنولوجيا الصينيه للمنطقه العربي همم
استاذ عبد العزيز بن رازن هل هذا اصلا همم
العالم العربي معني به خصوصا دول الخليج
هل معنيه
بصناعات العسكريه الصينيه
بموازنه الحلفاء او همم عقد التوازن بين
الحلفاء لكن ايضا في المجال الامني
والعسكري امام هذا حكر على شركات دول
الخليج تحديدا مع همم الولايات المتحده
وايضا الدول الاوروبيه
استاذ الفاضي هناك يعني من ضمن لرؤيه 20
30 اللي توطين الصناعات العسكريه وهناك
معرض الدفاع المشترك اللي عقد في مارس
الماضي وهذه هذا المعرض يعني كان مفتوح
لجميع الشركات العالميه ومنظم منها
الشركات الصينيه خصوصا التقنيه
والتكنولوجيا الصينيه دخلت حتى في جميع
المجالات حتى في الصناعات الغربيه بحكمه
المصانع يعني تقاربها مع بعض
وكلنا نعلم الطائرات المشيره او الطائرات
بدون طيار وكيفيه يعني تفوق الصين في هذا
المجال اللي يعني وفي توقع الشخصي هناك
يعني همم تعاون بين دول الخليج في هذا
المجال اضافه يعني همم يعني معلومه يعني
معلومه للجميع يعني المملكه يعني همم كلنا
نعلم الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه ومصنعها ومن
ومن اتات وتقنيتها وكيف يعني تم انشاءها
فالتواجد العسكري ربما لا يكون يعني واضح
للاعلام ولكنه متواجد في الدول الخليجيه
ولا استبعد يكون هناك يعني يتعاون قوي
ومنطرد في هذا المجال في الفتره القادمه
ماذا لو كان ذلك محل اعتراض من الولايات
المتحده مثلا
او عدم رضا
لو كانت دول الخليج والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تنظر لرده الفعل الغربيه لاتخذت
قرار ضد بوتن في حربه ولذلك اتخذت قرار
شادي وهذه رساله واضحه ان القرار السيادي
السعودي لا ترضى المملكه التدخل فيه ولا
انا موقف استشهد فيه ان الملك فهد لما
تدخل السفير الامريكي او خارج عمله في
الشانه الداخلي هل لها الملك فهد 48 ساعه
عليه الرياض وهذه رساله كافيه ان القرار
السيادي مستقل استاذ
يعني عاده في القمم والاجتماعات العامه لا
تظهر الخلافات لكن هل يعني هذا انه لا
توجد قضايا محل خلاف بين الصين والدول
العربيه خذ مثلا همم
[موسيقى]
ان لم يكن حاليا في المستقبل لانه يرفع
اسعار النفط
مثلا قضايا تهم العالم العربي ك همم قضيه
اللاجئين روهينجا الروهينجا وقضيه الايجار
هل هذه النقاط اصلا يمكن ان تكون همم تعكر
صفو الاتفاقات التي يجري ابراها
شخصيا اعتقد انه ليس هناك طرقات او خلاف
اساسيه بين الصين والدول العربيه انت ذكرت
همم اللي يغور في الصين
في لجنه حقوق الانسان عندما تصوت على هذا
الموضوع معظم الدول العربيه تدعم موقف
الصين وهذا مهم جدا وتلك البلدان التي
تعارض الموقف الصيني هي الدول الغربيه
وليست وبعض الدول الاسلاميه
الدول الاسلاميه
والدول العربيه
تتفهموا ما الذي تريده الصين
وتتفهموا ان الصين هي تدعم
بشكل كبير
يعني باختصار اذا هذه القضايا ليست
بالقضايا التي يمكن ان تعكر صفو العلاقات
دكتور خليل العناني اذا كان كما يقول
ضيوفنا ان هذا تحول فيه علاقته العالم
العربي وبحث عن حلفاء جدد ما خيارات
واشنطن في التعامل مع ذلك
اعتقد خيارات واشنطن صعب
علاقتها مع الدول العربيه خاصه بالعربي
ويحتاج ضمانات مهمه جدا بانه الشكل
استراتيجيه مع هندسه القائمه او موجوده
الامنيه الامر الثاني هناك مشكله حقيقيه
لما يتعلق بالصراع الامريكي همم الصيني
وبالتالي هناك حاجه الصراع من اجل عدم
السماح بدفع دول اخرى او حتى بدفع السنه
نفسها من اجل المنطقه العربيه يعني يعني
زياره الرئيس الصيني اليوم هي جزء من
اعاده موضوع على الساحه العالميه المحاوله
الاستفاده من وجود نوع من الفطور في
العلاقه الخليجيه الامريكيه تحديدا بالترم
حق الاستغلال هذه المساله من اجل علاقتها
مع الدول العربيه وبالتالي هناك خيارات
واشنطن قد تكون محدوده جزء منها متعلق
بالتاكيد على علاقات الاستراتيجيه مع
الدول العربيه خاصه الرئيسيه متعلق باعتاد
ضمانات امنيه
عن همم حمايه الدول العربيه خاصه الدول
المتحالفه معها لكنها بعدم حدود التوتر
فيما تعلم القضايا الداخلي حول الانسان
الى ذلك هل هناك في هذه المساله اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العراني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه واشكر ضيفنا من الرياض الاستاذ
عبد العزيز بن رازم المستشار بمركز
الاعلام ودراسات العربيه الروسيه ومن
بيجين اشكر فيكتور جاغاو رئيس الجمعيه
الصينيه للدراسات الدوليه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر عادي
[موسيقى]